we're here space is out there but space
is involved you know in our day-to-day
uh life even today maybe
people are not aware of that but
whenever you open your google maps
or waze and you start navigate right
basically all the navigation is
performed by connecting to satellites in
space
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leomi tech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
let's talk about space we have a very
special episode today with avi shabtai
ceo of ramon space avi is the ceo of
ramon space a leader in space computing
solutions
a seasoned leader avi has worked
extensively to develop and manage teams
transform organizations into successful
environments across multiple industries
avi's track record spends over two
decades of international experience in
business and technology leadership
marketing strategic sales channel
development and engineering
prior to ramon space avi was ceo of
multify inc
specializing in high speeds integrated
circuits for the data center market
he also held senior positions at
alvarian technologies metalink
the intelligence unit of the israeli
defense force avi shaptai welcome to 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm good i'm good good morning good
morning to you too
i'm really excited to talk to you not
about mornings or about even the tech
industry i'm talking i'm talking about
space today
you're the ceo of ramon space talking
about
computing in space and cloud in space
uh things that you know i don't think we
necessarily even think about in our
day-to-day lives or we take for granted
that the technology we have on earth is
obviously available in space but that is
not necessarily true
and i'm excited to hear from you about
your entrance into the space industry
from the technion
and from running other companies tell me
a little bit about yourself and let's
start with
community theater because i feel like
that's a pretty big part of your life
yeah it's actually it's been a big part
of my life i
i go to it by coincidence um
i really wasn't i wasn't prepared to do
anything like that i didn't know that i
would like it
and then i went to one session and i
kind of
fell in love and um it's been really
fun exciting uh in in some ways out of
this world
because um you know when you play on
stage you
get out of your own comfort zone and
then you get out there
and um and i can't you know there's
nothing like it i guess
i don't understand why people that
perform on stage have this kind of
high after uh after performing
it's uh incredible the way you can
interact with the audience and the
feedbacks it's like
um unbelievable it's really unbelievable
when you get that
kind of uh feeling i i recommend for
those who can uh
who can you know who have the guts to go
up there on stage and uh
be somewhere someone else for uh for two
hours
i used to perform in quite a few
musicals and plays in high school
and and i just remember the feeling of
the family
that we formed when we got on stage and
we had to you know work with each other
you know even without the audience just
us as a family putting up a product out
there
unbelievable right the process is also
yeah the process is also
fun you know it's uh
it's amazing avi tell me a little bit
about
space even before you tell me what
you're doing in space
give me the context we're here on earth
quite a ways down from the things that
are happening up there
what context do i need to know as a
young entrepreneur to even under to
begin to understand
why ramon space is relevant today
yeah maybe i'll start with something
that you know when i talk to people
about space so people tend to say oh
what it has to do with us
i mean we're here space is out there but
space is involved you know in our
day-to-day
uh life even today maybe
people are not aware of that but
whenever you open your google maps
or waze and you start navigate right
basically all the navigation is
performed by connecting to satellites in
space
uh whenever you watch many cases when
you watch tv you actually
watch tv through space so space is part
of our lives in a way
we may not be aware of that but it's
it's already there
now i think that if you take it to kind
of uh
the next level you i think mankind has
been always in a position to look for
something new and to
kind of open um get over the boundaries
where we live or what we do and i think
space is in this category
and i always like to use the uh the
example of uh
and and sorry if i'm thinking it's
really really uh far away from where we
are today
but you know in 1492 when christopher
columbus
uh got on a ship to
supposingly found some another world
i guess many people thought why do we
need i mean we have everything around us
we live here it's
it's okay so these uh crazy people that
went on that ship and
sailed risking their lives and so on uh
no one really thought it's uh it's got
any meaning but no one can say that it
didn't change the world right
so um i think mankind is always in the
you know on the verge of expanding
boundaries and space is the next one
we need to take into account that we've
been in space
no more about what's that about 60 years
or so
um that's pretty much it i think the
first satellite was launched in
1957 so
it's just the beginning of this journey
and um
so that's that's how is his face space
is another dimension or another
boundaries that
mankind is now uh penetrating
so i'm hearing i'm hearing that you know
while a lot of us have the context that
space
is you know this big elaborate thing
that is you know very futuristic you're
actually saying no it's actually in part
of our day-to-day
it's a it's a day-to-day thing that
we're using from
our navigation to our entertainment
and therefore it is hugely relevant to
probably any company that that arises
today and wants to interact with
customers
in one way or another what are the
limitations then that you're observing
in the space industry or or whatever is
happening out there
that requires a company like ramon space
yes so so i think the you know space
and john kennedy says we go to space
because space is hard
so space is is hard it's difficult to
get there
uh you know the environmental conditions
are
um are not easy for people to be but
also for electronics uh to work well
um we take into account i mean
what's ramon space is doing is we're
bringing super computing to space
but the essence of that is that we
believe that whenever we want
so we in the past to space we will need
to put more
computing more technology more software
more applications when you so that's
kind of um
a baseline where we start from and then
in order to do that we need to provide
computers that can really function and
work well in space
now the main i would say
things that prevent electronics from
working properly in space is you know
the radiation
which is very severe in space the
extreme temperatures um you know
the the vacuum i mean there is no air
you cannot
cool anything by just airflow so just
so that you need you need to make sure
that whatever you send there is really
going to work
and what we're providing we're providing
kind of super computers that can work in
space
function properly and enable whoever
wants to write
software or application to do it
seamlessly without thinking that
that they they need to develop something
for space
and kind of making the fusion between
what's happening on earth
and the ecosystem on earth to what's
happening in space
now was is this obvious to you
throughout your life that you know you
understand that there are these
limitations in space you go through the
technique and go through different
companies do you know that space is
is a place where you'll want to end up
because what i'm imagining
as a young entrepreneur i can't imagine
somebody waking up one day and saying to
you know what i'm going to build a
company that deals with space
it sounds so you know so
um you know black mirrory and so
complicated that you need such domain
expertise to even begin
talking about it or maybe i'm wrong
um yeah i didn't wake up one morning and
say
i want to get to space despite the fact
that people say it's karma because you
know according to my name it should be
obvious right but
um but um i i think it happened actually
through interaction with people that
were already involved in space
and uh i met uh manginosa who
founded the founded ramon space coming
from the
technion and um
i really connected to the um to the
concept and to the fact that space is
going to be the next
big market or big opportunity or
will have probably the biggest impact on
life on earth that's that's what i
really connected to
i think through um i guess through my
career i
was i was always exposed to new
technologies or new markets so i guess
it wasn't
um it wasn't scary to say okay let's get
to space
i mean it's in other boundaries you need
to to break and
uh it's possible and when you understand
the technology you know and the
the terms and conditions of everything
then you know okay it can be done
and um that's that's how i connected to
it
besides the fact that space you know
it's uh it's exciting
in a way in a sense it's uh um
in many technologies that we're doing
you know
we make we make an impact um on people's
lives and so but space has a much bigger
um uh potential for an
impact on on life on earth probably in
any
in any uh dimension you can think about
right and so we're talking now about
you know super competing in space where
i believe in one
one place i read you know bringing the
cloud to space
uh which made me also understand a
little bit that okay it's not
it's not trivial that the things that
we're building
here are going to be available for us up
there and we see so many incredible
technologies and advancements in cloud
computing
that right they're not necessarily
available in space but another part that
was interesting for me is thinking about
the commercialization of space
because i'm assuming that 20 30 years
ago you know you had
governments launch satellites and
spaceships and et cetera
for a startup to go and sell them super
computers it might not be that trivial
but perhaps
in the commercialization age or era that
we're in now
it seems like it's much more likely is
is that is that an important distinction
the commercialization of the space
industry
yeah suddenly because the
commercialization
i think uh brings two things one it
speeds up the
um um the pace
in which there are developments uh it
opens the door for
you know non-traditional way of thinking
and
to um you know to
to the way we're going to utilize in
space by delivering new services and so
on and
um it actually makes a difference i call
it a different money flow
because you know government has kind of
a way
how they work how they operate with in
many cases with traditional players
and uh with relatively long-term plans
at their own pace
where the commercial world is is faster
it's typically faster
it's open for disruption uh it enables
new
newcomers to come in and you know change
the rules of the game
and that's what it leads to and you can
see i mean you can see how
um the money flow and the new
initiatives coming into space
how they start to change the way people
work in space and the whole ecosystem
uh so it's no no longer you know it's no
longer a game of governments and
and i think that's a huge huge impact so
play a game with me and t and take us
you know a few years down the line you
choose how many years
what what is this ecosystem looking like
and how does ramon space
fit into this this ecosystem
you know one of the things that before i
answer that i think one of these people
asked me what's going to be in space
what's going to be in space
so first the first thing i'm saying
you know i don't know not because i
cannot envision
i don't know because it's kind of the
thing that is developed
and you know there are probably a few
tens of thousands of
entrepreneurs thinking of what they can
do in space that's going to surprise me
and you and probably everyone else
um i can tell you a little story from my
background you know in the
i think my first job was in a company
called metalink when we did
uh dsl you know adsl at the time vdsl
and the adsl was uh a technology that
was meant to connect um
high-speed connectivity to the to homes
and you know what is the main reason why
they won why adsl was invented
adsl is was invented in order to enable
the telephone companies
provide uh tv services
and competing with the uh with the cable
companies that's why
it's called adsl asymmetric because a
lot of streaming coming down and
uh but surprisingly nobody really used
it at the time for
um for tv services right it was used
actually for
the next big thing which was internet
access so
internet access was you know the main
use cases for adsl
and guess what 20 years afterwards
uh what's what is now i mean being uh
delivered over the internet lines i mean
what is the number one service
video services right but not in the way
people thought it's not
it's not a telephone company sending you
movies or tv services it starts to be
over the top type of services netflix
and
and amazon prime so this is just of
course
20 years ago nobody could have imagined
that this is the way that we're going to
be
you know getting entertainment it's just
unbelievable yeah
so the way i look at it look at space
and makes it uh
ten times more bigger in that's in that
essence and
so we're we're we're in our our humble
place
we're all we're saying you know we're
going to deliver to you computers that
can work you can start writing software
and services yes
it will start from communication from
navigation
earth observation but guess what there
will be other things you know people
talk about uh production
in space using space resources in ways
that we
maybe we didn't imagine landing on
asteroids and bringing new materials
um making uh you know making experiments
a pharmaceutical
experiments in space so
you know the dimensions start to to
develop
um and i really don't know how it's
going to
to evolve but it's going to evolve in in
ways which
definitely we do not imagine today
that's that's i'm sure
and and i'm also sure that computers
will be there
so that's kind of um my my thinking on
that
and i'm guessing that a big part of this
game as you're just you're literally
in the you know inflection point where
we see the commercialization right i
bought into the
i i put the down payment for the beta of
starlink
you know already you know i remember
having a um
some a representative from partner
coming here a few days ago to connect
the cables for my the new apartment
and i got into this debate with him over
whether partner
will have place in the industry in seven
to ten years
when we're when we're looking at what is
happening in space today but i'm
imagining
that for a company like ramon space
we're talking about computing
you need to be really open-minded and
you need to be really
open to all the things that are
happening around the space industry
because you have the opportunity to be
in all of them
you just have to find the right
opportunities right
correct yeah i mean you know sometimes
we talk to companies that uh
take pictures of earth and and or you
know videos
of earth and uh for example i was
talking someone saying let's say
for the sake of discussion that you can
open your
mobile phone and see a spot on earth
in real time whenever you want okay
you don't have it today but it's
possible uh
would it develop some sort of
applications that
uh could be interesting and be worth uh
uh earthy money probably yes
um and and that's just a small example
of things that can happen from uh
from space um you know
all the the real-time services and and
so on from uh
detecting things on earth they're not
there today and they are waiting
for computing to come and uh and support
it
i love it i i really really love it and
i and i i personally i get so excited
just
understanding how little i know about
what's happening in space
and and i'm only thinking you know a few
generations down the line how how
crucial part this is going to play
and getting rid of all this crazy
infrastructure we're building around us
and the infinite cables and the infinite
you know big poles that are that are
trying to to provide services and and i
get really excited about about the
thought of
of a potential future like that but for
now avi i have a few
fun questions for you are you ready go
ahead
all right so we'll start off easy your
favorite subject
in school that's middle school or high
school
um not really history okay
is there any specific part of history
that you're particularly fascinated by
um no i was just very intrigued by
my history it's really a story and um
i guess it's something to learn from
despite the fact that you know what is
the number one
uh um thing that you learned from
history
is that you never learn from history
whatever i i love that that's a really
good one
okay um one of your role models or
somebody that
inspires you you know i think in the
context uh very
much elon musk i think it's um
just the way i think he looks on um
how to get there in the future he i
think he's not
afraid to fail and and really
um is very focused on getting there
that's that's my
um so wonderful that's very impressive
and three words that you would use to
describe yourself
and and why those three specific words
for us say
creativity um
future and
and learn that's what i picked kind of
of my brain
describing me because i'm a pretty
creative
person i like to look at things
differently and think out of the box
um i always think ahead and try to see
it at work and outside work kind of
analyze maybe sometimes too much but
what's going to happen next what's going
to happen
next in autonomous and um and i like to
learn i'm very
curious and um i'm always in a kind of a
learning mode
so i think that's kind of uh that's what
makes me
avi thank you for coming thank you for
spending
time with me i know how busy you are i
learned a lot and
and i i'm really excited about about
where this is going and uh
i i just love the idea that we have here
in the israel ecosystem companies like
ramon space that are
that are thinking that far down the line
and um and they're open-minded and
creative
and are already preparing for this for
this new era that we're entering
and uh and really thank you for the for
the great insights and stories
it's been really great and until then
stay safe the whole thing
it's been a pleasure next time we'll do
it uh in space right
i'm taking you up on that thank you
today bye-bye
[Music]
you